with that being said let's talk about
what it means to be a real tough man
yeah this one I don't know you want it
you want to take it away this was yeah I
guess sure yeah it's uh it the title
here it's fake toughness versus the real
thing people who are really tough rarely
feel the need to show it hmm so let's
get into that so let's say an
observation the strongest men I know
guys who deadlift over 500 pounds run
four-minute mile for the mile run a
discus hundreds of feet or run ultra
marathons tend to be caring considerate
and generally calm dudes the guys I know
who want to be strong and tough but who
are not tend to be loud defensive and
overly proud seems pretty accurate right
so it says toughness isn't walking
around with your chest puffed out trying
to intimidate it's making the right
decision under uncertainty and distress
so let me let me let me interject yeah
go ahead
you know the reset the clock hashtag I
mean you know I'm going straight for the
throat what is it what is I don't know
so it's a meme that represents the how
many days it's been since a male
feminists assaulted a woman okay and
this this actually I'm going word for it
plays right into this that I'm thinking
about a regular guy okay who is not
interested in these like screechie woke
feminists types he's calm he's rational
he knows he's good he's confident he can
run a four-minute mile he can throw a
discus hundreds of feet and he's not
interested in playing these weird games
pandering to some woman who's screeching
in his face exactly what the male
feminists that's it there the chest
puffing whitey Knight needs to prove
something yep they gotta show I'll show
what they've got yeah it's like yeah
yeah well so there's there's a quote
toughness isn't walking around your
chest puffed out trying to intimidate
it's making the right decision under
uncertainty in distress strength isn't
yelling and shouting it's having the
inner resources to navigate storms I
like that a lot yeah look at this they
actually break it down now more than
ever it seems we are in we are in
desperate need of new masculinity just
imagine if we started to raise our sons
with the following core values I'm gonna
read through them first for describe
them wisdom real toughness vulnerability
humility authentic self security above
Wow yeah wisdom allowing yourself to be
open to and shaped by experience not
being scared of change and not being
scared to change wonderful real
toughness composure clear-headedness and
stability in the midst of uncertainty
not to be confused with machismo acts of
strength now hold on didn't weren't we
just told by the the American
psychologists or whatever that APA that
stoicism is like a mental disorder or
something toxic masculinity toxic
masculinity being calm and clear-headed
rational is considered toxic now now
hold on now the the writer actually was
talking about guys but I don't even know
if this is necessarily about men in
general because this can apply to women
also right you know it's like you can be
a tough human you know and and a weak
human and these still apply you know to
across the board you know what don't you
think yeah absolutely
look at this real vulnerability mm-hmm
putting yourself out there all of it
even and perhaps especially the
imperfections and flaws that make you
human I totally respect that yeah that's
exactly why I think people have been
saying good things about me because I'll
be like oh man I was totally wrong about
2018 I got no excuse for that
yep what am I supposed to say you might
have to pretend like I'm invincible yeah
I'm always right that's ridiculous or
ignore it
how many people do you it really bugs me
there are some progressives on YouTube I
talked to all the time and I've reached
out to one with like hey man I think you
got this one wrong and they refuse to
accept it refused to admit it hmm just
ignore it
III absolutely like I get messages and
they're like hey Tim I think you're
wrong about this I'll back Oh was I and
I'll go and immediately and be like hey
update correction I may have been wrong
about this yeah I really don't see the
issue with accepting that you're not
perfect I don't get it either but it's
the fake tough guys who yeah they're
always right mm-hmm
humility prove which brings me to
humility and humility
examine what you don't know which for
almost all of us is the vast majority of
everything exactly understanding
understand that your view of the world
is merely one of billions being curious
instead of narrow open instead of closed
you know the problem is all of these
things have been described as toxic
masculinity all of them you're right
yeah it's crazy they want I had that
was the guy here who's the doctor Shawn
Smith yeah great dude yeah yeah it was a
good it's like he was talking about the
importance of stoicism and being calm
and clear-headed like if you're driving
in your car with your wife and your kids
and you you crash and you've got to like
get out and fix the car right you have
to be calm you can't break down you've
got to make sure that you can be a good
leader so that your family is also not
freaking out and they're calm exactly
but imagine what they want for you like
when they say it's toxic masculinity
they want the husband and the wife to
start crying and doing nothing the men
the men must emote more then he would
just be sympathizing with his wife I
guess they're going candor yeah and her
to the woman tell her whatever she wants
to hear strategy it doesn't sound
appealing to be around any person like
that man or woman no I think I think the
big issue here actually is we get to the
root of this and the real issue is don't
be plastic hmm like be a real person
yeah yeah just be chill yeah don't
pretend don't make things up say what
you say what you say what you mean mean
what you say and some people show that
side of themselves and and very quickly
revert to plastic challenging yeah it is
it's like you know there's people get
triggered or uncomfortable or
embarrassed and instantly you know try
to you know squash it instead of like
you know really exploring it really it's
like what it what is going through my
brain right now what is happening you
know I'm asking that about themselves
you got a little more go yeah yeah
somebody not maybe not even just let it
go but understand it you got to learn to
understand it and you know if
something's happening you should delve
into that more you know and and try to
figure out what's going on well check
this out this is an interesting this is
a report I guess from the American
Council of science and health Oh
testosterone may make men more honest
this is really interesting they say
testosterone does a lot of different
things for men it masculines the
masculine eyes as the body boosts the
sex drive and contributes to hair loss
now researchers think it may also make
men more honest in recent years the in
recent years there have there has been
an interest in determining how our
hormones affect our economic behavior
such as gambling and financial risk
taking the financial engine industry is
dominated by men and if testosterone
influence
decision-making this potentially has a
profound implication for the national
economy paradoxically testosterone
promotes pro-social behaviors in some
circumstances and antisocial behaviors
and others the reason for this aren't
entirely clear but it may involve a
man's desire to increase his social
status previous research shows that
testosterone may actually make a man a
fairer negotiator to investigate the
phenomena further a team of researchers
administered testosterone gels to 124
college-age male volunteers and placebo
gels to 118 they were then given a dye
and told to roll it and whatever number
came up was the amount of money they
they were to receive for participating
in the experiment because they rolled
the die in private they could cheat by
reporting a higher value than they
actually rolled the authors hypothesized
that the testosterone group would be
more honest the results showed that both
groups cheated but the placebo group
cheated more which was consistent with
the team's hypothesis whoa whoa whoa
back to the male feminists low
testosterone guys lying to women to try
and get laid why am I not surprised it's
really interesting it's a weird thing
fake toughness no testosterone lying and
cheating behind the scenes these people
are made for each other
but what can a guy do it I guess boost
their testosterone if they are a soy boy
you're not a soy bro yeah got a workout
exercise driven experience I'm I you
know I think about the Tri guys the
BuzzFeed dudes who took the testosterone
test and they were like 30 percent of
average testosterone some ridiculously
low number super low yeah well I mean
there's a lot of data here that I'm not
gonna you know get into but they show
like the results of what people were
rolling and I guess they determined that
people were cheating because the
proportions made no sense based on like
so if you roll the dice at number of
times you should expect a certain
percentage of results but they were
skewing high meaning people were saying
giving higher numbers they get paid more
you know yeah exactly they say the fact
that two different studies arrived at
the same conclusion that testosterone
appears to make men more honest suggests
the effect is real however the failure
of the current study which was far
larger than the previous study to find
its own significant results further
suggests the testosterone effect on
honesty is rather
well in the long run I think it's kind
of obvious you know if that was the
correlation I'm not entirely sure but
it's obvious that guys who are sure of
themselves who are confident exactly
they have no reason to live
right they they they know what they're
doing they know what their path is
they're comfortable you know it's like
if you're comfortable when you lie you
you have to remember that and it changes
you know and then you you it adds an
uncomfortableness to whatever
environment you're in you know so if you
are telling the truth
it's really simple Linda it's really
easy but I also wonder if it has
something to do with how much you you
care right there's kind of a catch-22
where when when I don't know in what up
whatever let me start over
when talking about young guys who are
trying to hook up with women okay they
say that desperate guys never had never
seen a chance right because they they
come on too strong
they're very obviously desperate but
then you end up with a dude who's never
gotten laid becoming more and more
increasingly desperate and awkward
whereas the dudes who get laid very
easily become less desperate and they
don't care so now you have a bunch of
guys who are aloof and confident like
you know whatever I want whenever I want
I don't care and so now it's more
attractive that they're aloof and kind
of on their own whereas the desperate
guys increasingly you know struggle with
it so it's kind of like what I guess the
point trying to make is dudes who are
confident and tough and high
testosterone and don't need to try as
hard it's just it's it's coming to them
naturally which also makes them more
confident and more successful it's kind
of like there's two paths and if you
fall into the depreciated path if you're
going negative it's gonna be worse until
you can course correct and get out of
that pitfall yeah if you ever can if you
ever can you might end up as one of
these predatory male feminists
pretending to actually care about stupid
causes that no one actually cares about
because you're a liar just desperately
trying to get laid yeah it's almost like
a feedback loop if you can't do it
you're gonna feel like a failure if you
feel like a failure you'll never be
appealing and then you'll never know
yeah exactly and then you'll find out
that you you ended up as a male feminist
and like who would want to be one of
these people in a room full of people
that they're they're making fun of you
and yours like yeah like it's it's if
these guys who are sitting in the room
the women are like men are awful and the
male feminist goes aren't they
why would you sit there and take that
yeah defend yourself yeah I think they
respect you when you sit there and then
do that I don't get it it's not honest
no it's not
well somebody do not even enjoy living
do not enjoy yourself something you
can't sell some idly don't you know I'm
not you know not trying to like make
light on that but it's sad
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you